we've now we're here with two guests who
are rejoining us here we're going to
talk with Christopher Hitchins of Vanity
Fair good morning morning welcome back
thank you and we're gonna talk with
David from an author and a member of the
Manhattan Institute good morning to you
thank you what are you reading today
well the the first story that caught my
eye was the sword that was in both the
Washington Post and The Washington Times
a team of Columbia University
researchers has come up with some
disturbing findings about the rising
incidence of child poverty this is one
of these stories that is a profound
trend in American life but somehow never
seems newsworthy enough to actually
break break through the usual noise of
the broad friends here's what here's
what they found that the percentage of
children in poverty is up sharply over
the past 20 years and the numbers here
are probably better than statistics that
in 1975 there are three and a half
million children living in poverty and
today there are six million children and
living in poverty now what's striking
and the reason to look at both stories
is that the new to newspapers implicitly
give the Washington Post The Washington
Times different explanations of why this
is so and in a way this is the time
story we're looking at by the way okay
and in a way it sort of sums up a lot of
the ideological debate in America but
what's about what is going wrong with
the country the Washington Post story
follows the Columbia researchers and
believing that the main problem is the
declining rate of pay at least that's
available to the less skilled that it's
more difficult for people to for less
skilled people to find work so they are
poor and therefore their children are
poor the Washington Times story
emphasizes that is family status that
has everything to do with it that of the
children who are poor only 8% of poor
children live with a married mother and
father
92 percent live either the parents who
are living together common-law which is
usually a very short-term arrangement or
in single-parent households and so
they're they're you that you've got the
statistical evidence the facts right
there to come up with whichever view you
like is it child poverty as a result of
changes in the labor market child
poverty as the result of changes in
American family structure Christopher
Hitchens I'll give you a chance to
respond to that and you have a different
interest this morning as well
be said that there's something
superficially plausible about shortage
of money as an explanation for poetry
that I think revival was felt I mean
given all the I won't I would give it
its right now all the all the nonsense
talked about family values or the
incessant stress placed on them it is
still a pretty amazing reproach that the
number of children living an absolute
poverty should be going up in the way
that it has done in um in Sweden a few
years ago the the country I think
probably most disliked by the American
right maybe even more than kubera
sometimes think it was found that you
could take a child out of a class in any
school at random and run the ruler over
it in its teeth its skin it's calcium
rate of growth and all that kind of
thing and having Brotherhood over it you
could make no guess at all about the
social class or occupation of its
parents that's what I would call a
social democratic achievement imagine
how far one is in America from being
able to do that you can tell more or
less of it glance what the social class
version so a lot of people are just just
a thought I must say I don't think it's
some necessarily an antithesis what what
you put forward give the opening because
poverty is I often cause a family
breakup as is as is joblessness among
males and I think that it may be a
distinction without a difference to
suggest that one is a cultural and one
is a social cause of misery among our
children actually but family breakup
seems to be seems to be bigger than they
that that there were seven and a half
million children altogether born out of
wedlock in the United States last year
meant many of them to non poor people
that the rock III agree with Christopher
Hitchens this is maybe one of the top
two or three things that Americans
should be worrying about them and that a
quarter of the country's children are
growing up wardeness Christopher
Hitchens says that means that they're
never going to be as tall that means
they're never going to be as clever
because they're not fed properly when
they're young and it has it has huge
implications for the society
and they're not gonna be very good
parents and they're not going to be very
good parents it's some more issues and
more articles on the table here but
first we want to re-invite the viewers
to phone in with their questions
comments anything they're seeing in
their papers around the country we'll
put the split lines on the screen again
for you talk for a couple more minutes
and then start taking your phone calls
our guests this morning are David Frum
who is the author of this book right
here it's titled what's right came out
earlier this year right how's it doing
still we actually not too bad I'm away I
say that instead of a pleasant surprise
I was expect that these things are going
to vanish without a trace but it seems
to be selling in in in its niche
reasonably briskly I prefer the title of
the last one I must say which was by the
way dead right answer always I was kept
hoping would be more prescient that
actually was now you because for
Hitchens just got back from overseas I
did where were you and why didn't goes
with that just not all that last week
just for Thanksgiving I was in Cyprus
which i think is a very important
subject very much off the american radar
screen at the moment but i i predict
about to come back the situation of
cyprus is deteriorating i believe the
the overall rivalry between Greece and
Turkey is intensifying but the situation
in Cyprus itself is intensifying
independently that the church position
is becoming much harder they've just
adopted what I would describe as a
shoot-to-kill policy against people who
protest against the Turkish partition of
the island three people were killed over
the summer in cold blood as a result and
it's one of those stories that everyone
feels they know and has been filed away
on them that you can't file something on
a back burner County but you know what I
mean has been has been stored and looked
like a permanent petrified stalemate but
in fact the stalemate is is becoming
unstable and so I went to have a look at
that and trying to update my book on the
subject and you mentioned that it's sort
of a small arms build-up among two NATO
countries yes there is a there's a local
arms race going or we should concern
your viewers probably more than it does
in the United States is the principal
supplier of of heavy weaponry to both
sides both of the
both of the rivals in this case are
members of the NATO alliance in the
United States as the biggest exporter of
military hardware around the world is
the the armorer of birth in fact it also
a few better known in my opinion that
Turkey violates the United States
foreign assistance Act by using aid
military materiel given to it for its
own defense for the occupation and
colonization of Northern Cyprus and we
know you have an article that you
brought to the table here out of a year
this morning what's on your mind yes
sorry still to keep people overseas but
another thing that surprises me because
it's a thing one could have seen coming
at least a year ago is the implosion of
the Mobutu regime in Isaiah probably the
worst regime in probably the richest
potentially a successful country in
Africa and once again very much United
States responsibility general mabushii
was imposed upon Zaire by the Central
Intelligence Agency a long time ago he
he had his army and his appalling regime
are our business and they've got a very
short time now I would say to live or to
survive live in the case of mabushii
because he's dying of cancer and survive
in the case of the regime because it is
one man despotism and its army has
trained only to fight its own civilians
and is now gradually collapsing in
eastern provinces as the rebels get near
the capital if I was mr. Antony Lake I
would be calling urgent briefings at my
new CIA to find out what went wrong and
begin the inquest now stay overseas just
for a minute here actually it's it's a
the Chinese defense minister was in town
yesterday made a speech got a pretty
decent amount of coverage front page in
The Washington Times here this gentleman
defended the 1989 attack on Tiananmen
Square and actually claimed no one was
killed in the bloody confrontation as he
points out here and it responds to what
you say it's all a big misunderstanding
I have to say that I would if I were in
front page editor I would not put
Chinese I would not regard Chinese
Communist thinks it's okay to kill
people as a front page story that
strikes me as
as a dog bite bites Mansura if you found
a Chinese communist who thought it
wasn't okay to kill people that would be
a front-page story I'm amazed at the the
hold that some that the Chinese do to be
able to exert evoke of Washington and
and the the way that this must be the
third administration running that
they've managed to humiliate well it's
coming to office saying look we really
do intend to make human rights a
priority in our China policy and then
has has reversed itself now we have to
apparently this this guy go quite us a
warm reception world he spoke to was
treated you know was as an honored guest
I think it's a bit much he was according
to this article shunned by most
Republican members of Congress though
during during a breakfast reception on
Capitol Hill that's because it's the
Democrats turn to be groveling to China
it would it be the other way around if
it would be the Bush administration what
else are you reading the Republican
Party won control of the Texas Texas
State Senate for the first time since
reconstruction necessarily on page two
of this morning's Washington Post I
think it's in The Washington Times as
well and this is this is big big news a
governor George Bush in Texas is
planning a run for the presidency in the
year 2000 as I understand I don't think
it's generally understood how weak the
Texas governor is some of the weakest
governors in America is very little that
he can actually do to the left hand of
governor turns out to be actually more
powerful person in many ways than the
governor it's but the Texas is a state
run by his legislature and the
Democratic Party has managed to stave
off defeat in Texas for a long long time
I think the tide has now turned it is a
reminder of how a P phenomenal the whole
Clinton presidency is that the plane
presidency from the Democratic point of
view is sort of like getting your teeth
capped while your gums are rotting that
the top of the ticket is is still there
there's still a Democratic Party on top
but all the way down that the Democratic
Party is decomposing before our eyes
there's a lot of optimistic talk
at the Hmong Democrats at the time of
the election Christopher Hitchens uh I
guess you call corporate colleague
Sidney Blumenthal who writes for The New
Yorker a sister publication of entity
fare suggested that the story here is
that you know the Republican Party is is
is disintegrating and that we've now got
this this new Democratic coalition in
fact this is evidence of the underlying
strength the demonstrate for the
Republican Party in the underlying
weakness of the Democrats I like that
here being a corporate colleague of
Sidney's and I'm a great fan of his but
I I must say that I I'm inclined to
agree with you that the the success of
Clinton depends more or less on the
defeat of his party that he more or less
explicitly campaigned for Clinton
Gingrich 92 and and that's of course
what he got but it's I mean he didn't
campaign at all to try and get the
Democratic control of Congress but I
didn't mention it in his convention
speech to admission on the campaign
trail really I think Hannah had
internalized the idea that he owed his
recovery as a president to the defeat of
his party by Gingrich in 94 and the
Texas thing may not be the symptom of
that that you suggest but there's
nothing wrong with your underlying and
now since the Texas thing could also be
I suppose them taken as a symptom of
something else is long term to the
southern ization of the GOP the
president will be speaking to his party
or at least a section of the party today
about quarter past twelve we'll have the
speech here on c-span to the Democratic
Leadership Council it's a group that he
once headed Gerald Saab in The Wall
Street Journal today this will be the
most serious policy speech mr. Clinton
gives between his election and his
inauguration so it bears watching for
signs of what is to come in the next
four years the DLC is the is the living
refutation of all those who believe that
Clinton is a closet liberal I mean he he
he began his political career helping to
find an organization that wanted to move
the Democratic Party to the right and
he's now moved not as the party with the
entire country's to the right in a way
that probably no Republican could have
managed in such a short time so they'll
have lots to talk about when they get
together
well they he sir has this this strange
almost sick relationship with the
right-wing it was
he returns to them periodically for
strength and then he forgets about them
and drifts away and that he will
periodically make these these trips of
contrition and reunification with the
DLC but he had a big one big meeting
with them after the 1994 election I
think that was his first big speech was
the DLC again then he forgot about them
for a while and now he's been reelected
now he returns and I think that they're
they're like and it's like some
Victorian saga but the the mother of a
bad boy and he always shows up when he's
in trouble on mother steps weeping and
wailing and she takes him in and gives
him a meal and then he's off again back
to the saloons and I think that is I
wouldn't say that President Clinton is a
liberal on the other hand I think it
it's exactly the same kind of mistake to
say that he's a right-wing Democrat as
it is to say that he's a left-wing
Democrat
can't think what saloons you're talking
about or the fleshpots of liberalism
they go on well he what would be his
most conspicuous recent visit there well
yeah he in I mean I do know ambassadors
and fleshpots but well in the for
example he gave his a big black tie
dress to the DLC to the DLC after the
1994 election in which he said he would
be a good boy and not indulged in
irresponsible politics and do the kinds
of things they believed in the thing
they probably believed in more than
anything else is getting control of the
budget making sure that the they bring
the entitlement problem under control
and getting America's long-term fiscal
balance in order what Clinton then spent
the next 18 months doing was fighting
the Medicare battle in a way that is
going to make it immensely more
difficult to achieve any of the reforms
that the DLC believes in or that he is
now he has won the presidency honest
Logan no changes to Medicare well
they're going to be changes in Medicare
there must be changes in Medicare and
DLC people believe that more than
anybody and yet he himself by the way he
fought his election campaign the way he
outmaneuvered the Republicans in the
last Congress has made it
extraordinarily difficult to achieve
that and now he's there for absolution
and Raman Singh but in his second term
he's going to he is going to do exactly
what he promised not to do in the last
18 months of his first ever reversal in
the balanced budget amendment must be
worth any number of what anyone on this
to be election year amongst America in
the well if you'll feel totting up
ideological evolution I think it is
headline in the Wall Street Journal
concerning balanced budget as mr.
Hitchens pointed out balanced budget
amendment is up for grabs
over on Capitol Hill in house at least
while supports strengthens in the Senate
we've got a lot more we want to bring to
the table what we do want to get some of
the viewers involved here our first call
for David Frum and Chris Hitchens Dover
Delaware thanks for hanging on good
morning good morning
yeah good way I think they make a couple
of comments one one is that I've worked
in the hospitals for almost 20 years
I'm an anesthetist and I've participated
in abortions and as far as given
anesthesia for individuals who needed
them I've never seen one partial birth
abortion in 20 years I have seen
instances where the gynecologist has
made a wrong determination and the lady
is later on and the birth of the earth
and we realized and they've used saline
injections generally speaking to deliver
these babies that are you know close to
the full term but it's the only time
I've ever seen the baby of the sect it
was when they thought that the child was
much earlier than he was and that
already started abortion procedure and
they had to remove at time because it's
already dead that's the ones the other
thing is that the portion rights people
would spend more time trying to help the
living children who need help as you've
indicated earlier the number of poor
chill in this country is increasing no
one seems to care about them they're
worried about children are not even here
so let's take care of what we have right
here and maybe we can deal with this
other problem later we need to take that
as a comment it didn't it didn't seem to
be a question yeah I'll just throw this
one thought I don't think it's true that
the that a that not enough abortions is
the reason that there are more and more
children living in poverty and and even
if it were I don't think it would be I
don't think that it would be the best
solution to the problem of the increase
of the number of children poverty to rec
and aborting more of them though to
Potomac Maryland our next call good
morning good morning I just like to have
two questions actually the Republican
gentleman there yes does he support the
Chinese actions right now with the
different things that's going on in
China well I'm not a if that's directed
to me I'm not really much of a
Republican III don't know how the caller
would think that it that with the chart
that the actions of the Chinese
Communist government are in some way or
other the default or the responsibility
of the Republican Party Paulo you want
to respond to that my answer yes well
there's no the Republican Party is the
the Republican Party of the
ideologically anti communist party that
is always being attacked for its in fact
in flexible and rigid attitude on
questions like like communism so I don't
know that I don't know that I don't know
that and they're very many Republicans
who would endorse the actions of the
Chinese government well I guess I really
didn't have the the the right question
but I really had in my head was the
one-child policy that they have in China
okay we just and Claire which is a very
fascinating policy because if you think
about it it means that in a generation
or so there would be no realistic word
for brother or sister which would be a
very odd thing for communist society to
find that it had created not - not to
mention the thought of Society of a
billion people all made up of only
children by the way talking of that you
see that Freud's comeback in Russia
Lenin was very keen on Freud and you
know started after [ __ ] revolution
to encourage psychoanalysis among Soviet
citizens Stalin thought that it was bad
and no doubt had eatable reasons of his
own for back for repressing it
completely banning it and now it's it's
been legalized again psychoanalysis in
Russia but if they're gonna need it in
China if they have a billion only
children and there would no no not just
no word for brother and sister but no
word for aunt or uncle quite soon so the
fraternity bit of liberty equality and
fraternity will be down the tubes what
else you got your eye on today um i one
other one other thing in that same that
same front page below the fold the
merger of st. Luke's I guess it isn't
political the st. Luke's and Beth Israel
Hospital in New York again this is this
is more of a trend story than a big news
story but it's an example of how since
1992 93 and been amazingly enough
constant coinciding with the defeat of
the so-called Clinton reform that
American medicine through the
marketplace has completely reinvented
itself now a lot of reinvention has been
has been experimental and innovative and
there been a lot of disappointments and
failures along the way but in fact
exactly the problem the President
Clinton campaigned in 1992 on and saying
that only government could solve that is
the rise in crime rise in medical costs
and the shrinkage of the number of
people covered by private health
insurance is in it's a crude lumbering
often brutal way being directly handled
by the American marketplace that costs
have have come down the rate of medical
inflation has fallen to below 4% over
the past three years Americans are
switching from traditional medicine to
HMOs as a result the number of people
who are losing their coverage is being
stabilized and stories like this I just
said give us periodic glimpses of a
marketplace that is being reinvented in
a creative way and it warns us that just
as we now see that the 1993 Clinton
health plan would have aborted a lot of
these important changes that we have to
be very wary of what the president plans
in his second term he again plans to
moong
this time in a more cynical and
opportunistic and less coherent way than
in the first term with the American
healthcare marketplace and again this
should be stopped there are there are
always going to be horror stories when
you have a marketplace that is churning
and reinventing itself as rapidly as
this one but on the whole that this is a
story of immense creativity and dynamism
and it should not be interfered with
any thoughts yo Canadian not sure you
are your refugee from the single pad you
can city also I'll be listing the
summary line of the Canadian healthcare
systems Canada is a great place to be
when you're not sick that if you twist
your ankle
I'd much rather twist my ankle in
Toronto than in Washington I go to a
hospital the doctor looks at me I come
out again no paperwork no forms to fill
out
if however I'm sick if I need an MRI if
I need a cat scan if I need a world
level surgeon I would much rather be in
the United States and in Canada that
that for all its bureaucracy and in
inefficiencies and inconveniences the
American system does do a better job of
providing high technological medicine
the Canadian there more I think I think
they're more cat scan machines in
metropolitan washington than in all of
Canada well there's a richer country to
it I mean as someone who was caught up
in them broader I can't believe that one
couldn't close the technical gap without
some compromising the principle of
health care I mean I I just I think it's
just extraordinary that this country in
South Africa are the only countries that
could be described as advanced which
don't have a national health provision
of some kind or another and my
experiences with with it here seem to
persuaded meet anyway they can buy the
worst of capitalism with the worst of
socialism I mean you can turn up and if
you haven't got a Visa card on you
they'll send you away but the amount of
paperwork and bureaucracy and and paper
shuffling and duplication of work that's
involved in doing it is absolutely
terrifying and would disgrace a
Stalinist Banana Republic and yet it's
all for profit as I converted England by
the way but in his national health
health health health treatment is a
right and written and it's the one thing
of the of the the post with one aspect
of what achievement I should better say
of the post-war Labour government
the not even mrs. Township dad to touch
I don't know what the British situation
when I would compare the United States
in Canada is in Canada we have these
immense queues for all kinds of
important operations everyone has
insurance in Canada but not everybody
gets care in the United States it turns
out almost everybody gets care although
many people lack insurance so so there's
a choice I won't defend the American
system it's obviously it's it's it does
combine the worst of both it's also by
the way a system in which the government
looms very large that's the cause of a
lot of the problems the federal
government is the single largest
purchaser of health care in the United
States but as this story shows that the
private market has tremendous creative
potential in the United States and it
shouldn't be it should be wet free well
the type of mother certainly knows how
to do moat mergers but I felt I knew
that already
that 1/2 hour left David Frum and Chris
Hitchens Aurora Illinois you've been
hanging on good morning good morning mr.
Hitchens two quick questions on my point
can you give me your opinion of the
daily uninspired socialist Labour Party
number two you recall earlier in the
year the SEC investigated the Nasdaq
market makers for corruption I was
hoping you were your friend over at
counterpoint Alexander Kohlberg could
look into the market makers equivalent
on the New York Stock Exchange the
specialists I've heard they are deeply
corrupt and have massive conflicts of
interests no there's a wonderful article
in the newest edition of the progressive
magazine by Elaine rapping called
burrowing within that addresses the cult
of individualism I spoke to you once and
suggested this far more of a threat than
the religious right is the ein Rand
inspired libertarian right what makes
them so insidious is that under the
guise of self-help and therapy they
spread they're deeply ideological
pro-corporate message consisting chiefly
of the lie that life is what you make it
when anyone who's ever had a Walmart or
McDonald's come to town or worked inside
these fascist multinationals knows the
opposite is true that life under
capitalism is what corporations make it
and Mister from I don't have to say that
the government of China is about as
communist as Pat Robertson as a
Christian thank you it's a lot out there
go ahead and react that's a that's a
very high standard of cool for this time
of the morning I mean not but it's I
think it's the the opening bid is a
little arcane to some people Daniel
DeLeon was a great American
list rather dogmatic rather schematic
thought by some who ran for president on
the social slaver ticket and fairly the
party which still bears the that name
was still produces a socialist weekly
call I believe the people James Connelly
the great Irish Republican socialist
revolutionary who was murdered by the
British after the Easter Rising got his
early training in Dan'l delay on
sparking but let me see on the Nasdaq
I'll have to pass I'm sorry I just don't
know enough about the sec and I was
taken and I missed that story as for
what you asked about Iran and her
influence on the American right I think
it's I think it's extremely interesting
there is a strain of the show a lot of
people watching this have read either
Atlas Shrugged or The Fountainhead and
perhaps imbibed some of the the Randian
doctrine which is best summarized I
think in her book the virtue of
selfishness I always thought it quaint
and rather touching that there is in
America a movement that thinks the
people are not yet selfish enough and
I've met some of its supporters they
call themselves Objectivists and I've
debated with them but I've never got to
the bottom of that problem they think
that really America as a society already
rotten with too much socialism and
compassion and it's just so refreshing
to me people who managed to get through
their day actually believing that the
discussion here is getting very broad in
terms of issues we folks look for when
you look at the paper in the morning why
look for I look for the Style section
actually it's always sort of a fight to
get to admit that no I became a
journalist because I didn't want to have
to rely on the newspapers for
information and I can't imagine what
it's like for people who only do get
their information that way I mean I get
all my information I think we're talking
to other people in Washington I read it
basically for entertainment and I follow
the op-ed pages pretty closely to the
reason I asked the question is because
there's a story about what what's hot on
the radio we've covered an event by
talkers magazine yes
wanted to compare your top ten to this
top ten these are what radio talk show
hosts say are the 10 hottest topics we
write down the list and have you add or
subtract from your own list presidential
and local elections quote scandal gates
several varieties crash of TWA flight
800 Olympic bombing the value jet crash
Unabomber life on Mars the army sex
scandal the OJ Simpson trial and Texaco
's racial problems whoops
compare and contrast there to your list
in terms of interest a half a dozen of
them about half of them I can't imagine
what what there is I can't imagine what
there is to say
but the valujet crash for example that
would fill up time on the radio that
it's a terrible a terrible thing but I
think that unless it's part of some kind
of conspiracy worldview like as I think
has happened to the TWA actually it's a
bids to do with the fact that people on
the staff go valujet were warning us
before this crash that the the were
terrible corners been cut doesn't
wouldn't that be the thing well I don't
know what that what I don't know what
there has been Connor would mention its
corners being cut yeah I I don't know if
that's exactly why it is that this is so
exciting to the people on talk radio I
would move life on Mars much higher up
know quite well there were some
revelations I would yeah actually now I
look I think it's all read a book once
by that a man I do look for in the paper
is John Noble Wilford the science writer
of The Times The New York Times she
wrote a wonderful book called Mars
beckons about the possibility know that
there is life on Mars but that life
could be created there the conditions
for it exist and that by seeding Mars
Euler a complete crap what we're saying
by seeding Mars with with nitrous oxide
and so on you could create clouds which
would one day create rain which one day
create life this is a real possibility
apparently absolutely enthralling work
the Welkin one could organize a Genesis
moment for Mars and then stand back I
hope Wilfred doesn't talk to his
economic colleagues at the New York
Times about this because they'd be
worried about what this would mean for
the trade deficit and I was also must
say I was kind of thrilled to find that
there may be water on the moon after all
or at least ice therefore possibly water
because it means we won't have to take
any there and that possibly something of
a similar process could be inaugurated
up there too it's more calls in Bel Air
Maryland don't you
you're next Bel Air go ahead good
morning morning my comments are for mr.
Fromm who seem to have some nasty things
to say about the Canadian health care I
recently attended a wedding in
Connecticut and most of the guests were
from Canada and while they were there
the mother of one of the guests had
fallen and broken a hip now the extent
of the medical care in Canada is such
that this woman didn't even feel
compelled to run home there was spent
medical care and home care available to
a side law also like to point out
recently a couple of years ago mr.
strongest ex-senator strongest made a
comment that if he had his condition
which required bone marrow transplant in
Canada he would have died I think he
failed to mention that the procedure for
bone marrow transplant was perfected in
Canada and there was nobody there at
that wedding I took that occasion to
bring up the the state of medical care
in Canada and everybody raved about it I
would also point out to mr. frohm that
his comment about the horrors of some of
the abuses in our own system and not as
anecdotal as you would seem to imply
8000 women were sent home the same day
having a mastectomy to me that that is
not a minor our story but it was a small
percentage of the women but that it
should happen at all I would also bring
up the drive-by delivery situation well
let's let's get a response although I I
think the the drive-by delivery is sort
of an unfortunate actually comparison
because drive-by deliveries are now the
rule in Canada that everybody in Canada
unless you have an extreme condition is
sent home within 24 hours also the
babies are left in the room that clay
clothes and most
Leeson most the toronto hospitals i
think this is the case in the poorer
parts of Canada they've closed the ink
they closed the incubators except for
the high-risk babies you get the baby
right away because there isn't money for
nurses yeah I mean it's it's true but
Canadian medical research there are a
lot of brilliant people working in
Canadian universities but the Canadian
medical situation is exactly what you
would expect it to be in a society where
you pay an english-speaking Society
adjacent to the United States where
doctors are paid and and more skilled
they are the more true this is something
between third and one half what their
American counterparts are paid in which
patients in which the only check on
patients patients are don't see a bill
so the only check on their use of the
system is top-down administrative
controls and in which governments try to
control cost by making sure by reducing
the amount of Technology in the system
it behaves exactly the way you would
expect it to be hit Lafayette Louisiana
you're next hello hi yes I'd like to
talk to mr. Hitchens about a national
healthcare in Britain I don't know how
you think it's wonderful I'll just give
you one example my sister needed surgery
for a hernia it took two years before
they finally admitted her and if she
couldn't have gone that day when they
called she would have to go on the list
again on a waiting list they finally did
the surgery on her she was in terrible
pain it did put it called keyhole
surgery over there after six hours she
was still in surgery
him he had to open her up and go in the
what he did was you've ruptured her
spleen and he had to take her spleen out
and now she's on antibiotics for the
rest of her life
so if she was as in this country she
would be a millionaire and I don't
believe in suing doctors but this is
just one example of the national health
care in Britain my father died because
of the national health care in Britain
we all see wonderful the doctors come to
your house they came to the house twice
in the middle of the night from my
father and ignored it and by the time
the doctor dinner GP came in the morning
after his court surgery hours he was
sent to the hospital died in the
ambulance was an aneurism
so don't tell me it's wonderful the
doctors have house calls it doesn't mean
a damn thing all right call tell us more
about it
I think I've said initially that it's
the only one of British Labor's post-war
institutional accomplishments that even
mrs. Thatcher felt she she couldn't
challenge but that doesn't need to say
that the service hasn't become extremely
rundown and hasn't had grave cuts
inflicted on it and I've heard actually
I can't say I've heard a story as bad as
the one that the lady just told us
sounds absolutely frightful but I've
heard the story is not dissimilar and
and more of them recently as the service
has been allowed to fall into disrepair
but it still upholds the principle that
health care is a is a rightness
available to all and that that principle
is imperfectly observed doesn't seem to
me to be a criticism of what I said
we have a call from central South
Carolina what's on your mind yes I have
a comment and a question for Chris
Hitchens mr. Hitchens I have heard that
you are an atheist and I was wondering
if that was true because I mean because
I think you're much too intelligent to
be an atheist and you seem to have a
really good heart
so I'm wondering why you don't believe
in God and I hope that you're not basing
your concept of what Christianity is on
the Pat Robertson model because believe
me he does not speak for me and I
consider myself a born-again Christian
and he does and says a lot of things
that are completely missed field as far
as I can tell so I would encourage you
to maybe look at a magazine ex-soldier
owners I don't know if you're familiar
with it but there's that model - of
Christianity and I'm wondering if you've
ever considered that and how that
affects your faith or lack thereof
well you seem to have a good heart too
though how you can tell about mine I
don't know I would caution you not to
judge a book by its cover
I have read sinners and I've met the
people who work there and very nice they
are - but not even they will convince me
that I owe my presence in the studio -
divine design I don't believe I was
divinely designed I know do I believe
I'm divinely supervised as I go about my
daily tasks I've decided that there's
simply no reason to believe it and so I
don't conversion moment here these pins
going to blinded by the light no it's
just I just think that the whole
hypothesis of us being created is now I
think that's very nearly you can't of
course totally disprove the existence of
God you can simply say there's no reason
to believe in his or her existence I
think the idea of the divinity as the
Creator has now pretty much been well
rendered unnecessary as an assumption we
have alternative explanations how we got
here but it it isn't really religious to
say you believe that you're created it's
much more religious to say that you are
worship to someone who is supervising
you who takes an interest in your
thoughts and your daily doings I just
find that quite impossible to believe
and quite unnecessary to believe and
there it doesn't have to issue in
superstition and bigotry and foolishness
of the Pat Robertson kind it makes a
very good nursery for that sort of thing
because it's fundamentally solipsistic
and narcissistic to believe that that
you are the adored object of a of a
diminishing skater mister from back in
any other articles thank you so I think
there's about those were the the big
ones of the day what seems to happen I
was III I often wonder whether it's the
supply of news that fluctuates or
whether it's journalist appetites for it
that I wonder whether in fact so many of
the best journalist in America don't
schedule holidays for the two weeks or
three weeks immediately after an
election that you notice that your
newspapers become become very very thin
and they become filled with stories like
I mean with all due respect to for
Sigmund Freud the front page story in
the New York Times on on the Russians
rediscovering Freud that had the feel of
a story that was written maybe three
months ago that was being saved for the
day that all their political
correspondents took their post-election
holiday would you classify this story in
that category we talked about this a
little bit earlier the story is charming
this is really this is Dick Morris the
former aide
to the President to who left it or the
end of the campaign there he's pushing a
book that he has out in a picture here
has him speaking to a class at NYU New
York University in the city there and he
talks about his prescription for a
comeback
three points number one apologize you
have to recognize your sins number two
don't make excuses and three consider
yourself inoculated from further
questions and criticism and as Susan
page writes that his comeback road is
dauntingly uphill well that's that last
sentence is much too optimistic it isn't
at all
appeal and he's already back in the
newspapers no I think he will be
astonishingly easy at the essence of the
Dick Morris method seems to be don't
confuse the fact the verbal formula of
an apology with actual contrition
because if you really were sorry you
wouldn't be able to help coming back to
the subject again and again and again
but but he seems to see it as a kind of
like amulet you say I'm sorry and that's
it the subject is closed and then you
tell the reporter from USA Today with
five million readers when they ask you
for the question the American people
aren't interested in this and you think
we'll defeat the people at USA Today
must have some expertise in what the
American people are interested in they
sell five million newspapers to them
every day they hate he is he is what
what Emerson called a representative man
I think he's just one of the most
characteristic figures of our time and
he's fascinating New York Times
following that story as well Chris
Hitchens any reaction come back I didn't
think he'd even been away I mean if by
the way he's another instance of what I
mean about the president this is a man
who went from working for Jesse Helms to
working for Clinton and designed his
reelection strategy so I think we that
really does lay the closet liberal thing
to rest it more than that though this is
the sort of person
iced when I was at school to be able to
grow watercress on my sponge it was a
thing we were able to do boarding school
with you if you let your sponge rot for
long enough you could grow watercress on
it in the only absolute decay and
debauchery of American politics and that
the takeover of it by soft money
and spin doctrine a certain kind of
culture will grow in that from grubby
dish and this this type is is the sort
of thing we get and he has more
influence on the way elections are run
in the way this president thinks than
many 10 senators in his words dick
Morris's words on President Clinton will
read a quote here New York Times what
Clinton does is what any good sailor
does he tacks the wind is blowing this
way so he goes toward the exit sign but
he goes like this way and then it's
blowing this way so he shifts his sails
and he goes that way he's still working
his way toward the exit sign but he's
not being an idiot about it and then he
goes a little this way and a little that
way and hands up where he wants to go
political wisdom it's just drivel
for thing there's no exit sign when
you're sailing I mean nobody people
think oh what a masterly nautical
metaphor the guys are complete idiot but
there's no such esteem is disgrace
anymore there's no justice humiliation
there's no such thing as shame all there
is is either celebrity or at worst
notoriety and this guy's the proof of
this and a match what makes you you can
hardly hold it hold it down looking at a
picture of that night about 20 minutes
left for the newspaper roundtable
Sarasota Florida you're next
good morning a couple things one of them
is we have people that make a conscience
fiscal responsible decision and how many
children they should have let me turn
around and have to pay taxes for people
that don't make that decision
there's also millions of people that
want children that can't happen is there
any any thought to letting people that
have the physical availability adopt
children from people that can't afford
them that happen anyway
kind of a redistributive scheme of
children um that's not a subject I've
I've given a lot of thought to I I have
to say you touch out an abortion in your
book I don't think so not no not that
one I touched on a little bit in in the
first and talked about its its impact on
on the Republican Party and it's it it's
it's been big and but I I think that the
people I I take very seriously the views
of people who are who are anti-abortion
I think that they are when they are
often represented as as you know they
they get a very bad press I mean
compared to other other political
minorities but you know III think that
the question of of child poverty and why
they're poor children is a separate
question really from fertility fertility
rates in America been declining steeply
over the past thirty years that the
reason there are more poor children the
reason they're more abortions is not
because they're more children being born
in fact there are many many fewer
children being born per women for poor
woman than then was the case twenty
years ago when America seemed to do
better in twenty or thirty years ago in
America seem to do better by by it's
more numerous relatively more numerous
children but I think a question was
looking for answer on adoption not
abortion wasn't here I mean the the the
tragic fact is that there are a lot of
people who can't have children and it
must be awful for them I've so often
tank reading stories of all about
abortion thinking cuz there are people
who who could have a child and don't
want and didn't want you it he increases
their misery I was the sponsor once of
of an adoption but for a childless
couple there you have to get people to
say you're okay and you can pay the
bills and so on and they they flattered
me by asking me to be one of their
sponsors are what amazed me was how much
they were perfectly solvent and
professional and responsible and they
met all the tests very easily but they
had the devil's own job getting hold of
a child they could raise and what struck
me was how much this business is to
control by the churches it's very very
hard to get over the
child looking for home unless you have
some confessional way into doing it and
I can't believe that there couldn't be a
better national adoption service method
of matching people who want to give a
child away to those who would love to
make home for one company we can't do
better than this let's go to LA another
call from there hi I wanted to draw your
attention to the front page story in the
LA Times yesterday concerning Arizona's
prop 200 concerning the de facto
legalization of a series of illicit
drugs much of the attention has been
focused on 215 in California which was
the Medical Marijuana Act they're
claiming in this article that the
Arizona initiative is going to be a
model for drug legalization throughout
the entire United States and since it
was passed by two out of three Arizonans
as a similar number of Californians on a
similar subject I was wondering if the
gentleman could comment I have I have to
say I'm a heretic on this question I
think that makes a lot of sense at least
for the less serious drugs you know that
one of the things that I've always been
given to understand it but why the
homicide rate in Washington DC was so
much higher than it is in almost any
other American city even cities with
contra they're 350 homicides last year
which is considered a great achievement
it's down from 500 have a half a dozen
years ago is that in Washington the drug
trade has always been completely
disorganized New York and Philadelphia
in Chicago there are criminal criminal
syndicates but still syndicates that
understand who has control the channels
of drug distribution in Washington
that's not in the case of these open-air
drug markets very lucrative trade and
people get butchered over it and I have
to think it would be better for
everybody if you took this trade out of
the hands of criminal syndicates put
into the hands of respectable companies
that Democratic presidential candidates
could demagogue gain state election time
the evil tobacco marijuana complex but
but ensure that it was regularized that
the prot level of profit and the
industry came down and that it wasn't
worthwhile to butcher people over it I
yes you would have a rise in in
addiction I have no doubt about that
you'd have a fall in the murder rate I
think I think
that would be a fair trade that's a very
heretic alot nowadays but I think it
would be a good I couldn't agree more I
think I'm very heartened to find that
despite or the incessant ridiculous
hateful self-evidently contradictory
propaganda about the war on drugs that
when American voters roster audit that
shows this public and has had no effect
I'm it really cheers me up to think that
restores one's faith in the in the in
the thinking voter I think
decriminalization of drugs is long long
overdue it will be looked back on when
it is done as what was all that about
how did we let Richard Nixon declare war
on drugs and ruin so much of our society
throw away so many of our liberties
incarcerate so many innocent people deny
ourselves in the case of marijuana so
many potential remedies how did we ever
let this prohibition go as far as it has
done I would add to what David Frum says
that not not just would be a great
decline in the murder rate because I'm
not threatened physically at all if
someone in my building or on my blog
wants to put a substance into their
system which is their writings none of
the government's business that doesn't
threaten me at all
or does threaten me is the people who
will shoot at each other in the street
for the right to sell him that stuff if
it's illegal the second thing that
terrible consequence fail consequence
that arises from that is of course
tremendous corruption whole police
departments have been lost to the drug
trade and then I think it won't be long
before there will be judges too it'll be
much much worse than Chicago in the 20s
and it already is pretty bad that I
think that's the moment probably at
which decriminalization will be
considered forcibly by the authorities
so they'll have to do something about it
but I think it's appalling once you have
to wait that long let's go out to
Columbus Ohio good morning yes I'm a
first-time caller and hopefully I won't
get so nervous that I will sound like a
blithering idiot here I'm always struck
by how poor the concept is of what it is
to be poor having been there and
certainly all of my childhood I was
probably poorer than even
the the poorest in the inner city I I'm
I'm really struck by what people think
that it really is like let's get a
definition from each of our guests
how do you define poor yeah I'm not sure
I exactly understand the caller's
question I would i would define poverty
as someone who in a rural area has a
family has the family income of less
than $10,000 in the city has a family
income of less than $15,000 well
actually that would have been very
wealthy for the standard that I grew up
in and I am mr. Hitchens particularly
when he said he didn't feel that they
can grow up to produce be a good parent
etc I want I want to say that it has
nothing to do with money it only has to
do with character and fortunately even
though if you took my childhood and put
it on the scale it would have met the
very worst circumstances but I had a
mother who was very bright and who had
character and and those are the concepts
more than money that we really need the
poor are different from us scott
Fitzgerald famously said they have less
money I don't think you care if I put a
figure on it because the definition must
I think mean that you if you're poor it
means you you are not sure where your
next meal is going to be or and you're
not certain that you know where you're
going to sleep or not you're not secure
in your habitation I think that's to be
absolutely poor it is to not have any
confidence in the availability of the
bare necessities
of course it is true as the lady says
for herself and my profession for others
that many people have triumphed over
upbringing of that kind and we and we
know their stories we probably know them
of course it was there the survivors
there are people who didn't make it and
my point about people later on becoming
poor parents to use poor in another way
ma'am was at
directed toward a friend was saying
about the relationship between poverty
malnutrition and intelligence I mean
it's been shown that children who have
badly ma-na nourished in the early days
will have lower IQs for example so that
doesn't of course of lower IQ doesn't
necessarily mean you know be a good
parent but you know what I mean the odds
tend to lengthen it about at that point
time to get in couple more calls let's
go to Buffalo first go ahead yes good
morning gentlemen a comment and a
question the comment relates to mr. mr.
Flom and the Canadian healthcare system
I live up here in Buffalo and it's about
five minute drive from Canada and I
would challenge mr. Flom to come up with
the name of one major Canadian
politician who has suggested politically
that they abandoned the national health
care system that he condemned so much
for anything that we have down here but
my my real question is this perhaps for
both gentlemen why does mr. Clinton who
now has been reelected for four more
years can't run again
why can't he operate from the gut
instead of continuing to have his finger
up to the political wind to see which
way it's growing well I'll leave that
second question to Christopher Hitchens
who probably is keener insights and I
into the president's psychology after
the first why is no Canadian politician
called for the abandonment of a system
that is demonstrably now failing why
does no American politician acknowledge
that social security is in danger of
going bankrupt I mean there there are
things that that the mere fact that
something is true doesn't mean that it
is safe politically to say and in Canada
the two things one is that the problems
of the health care system have been
intensifying over the past half a dozen
years it actually did work although the
problem that the inevitability of some
kind of crisis was there from the
beginning it worked reasonably well
until six or seven years ago it's begun
to go wrong since then and and second
and second that for Canadians of course
is the caller in Buffalo will know the
health care system has significance way
way beyond whether it's doing a good job
or not it's an important touchstone of
national identity and at this point to
acknowledge to acknowledge in Canada
that the healthcare system is false it
is the equivalent of the night of
nology the flag could be more beautiful
it's just something you don't say one
more comment you mentioned we've been
talking about the president you
mentioned soft money earlier and
campaign one story we didn't get to
bring up but we'll bring up real quick
here is the White House is considering
whether to open fund raisers attended by
the President to the news media as a
response to the public furor over
questionable campaign money they talk
about potential how much they have to
pay to attend well they talk about
potential problems but the dynamics of
those me well that drives me wild with
annoyance because during the actual
election campaign when it would have
been worth knowing and worth attempting
I couldn't even get the Democratic
National Committee to tell me which
fundraisers the president had already
attended they considered that to be
their private business as indeed it was
but if I be if I'd run up and offered
the money they would have given me a
straight answer and perhaps an
invitation but if I didn't have any
money they weren't interested the the
franchising of politics and the sort of
people to him it's being franchised by
these real sweeties in Indonesia is the
scandals and the scandal as my friend
Mike Kinsley wants to put it so well in
Washington is never what's illegal the
scandal is what's legal last thought I I
am I am amused by the I mean there's the
Dick Morris rule again we asked did he
make a comeback there it is you of how
you issue your proform apologize apology
and then refused ever again to
acknowledge that anything went wrong and
then change the subject and say what we
now need of course is a vast new
regulatory statute it's always great to
hear from both you David from for the
Manhattan Institute and I Christopher
Hitchens of Vanity Fair thanks a lot for
joining us thank you and we'll be back
in a couple minutes